my name is dr roy guerrero i'm a
board-certified pediatrician and was
present at uvalde memorial hospital
the day of the massacre on may 24 2022
at robb elementary school
i was called here today as a witness but
i showed up
because i am a doctor
because how many years ago i swore an
oath
and oath to do no harm
after witnessing firsthand the carnage
in my hometown of uvalde
to stay silent would have betrayed that
oath
inaction is harm
passivity is harm
delay is harm
so here i am not to plead
not to beg or convince you of anything
but to do my job
and hope that by doing so it inspires
the members of this house to do theirs
i've lived in uvalde my whole life
in fact i attended rob elementary school
myself as a kid
as often as the case with us grown-ups
we remember a lot of the good and not so
much of the bad
so i don't recall homework or detention
remember how much i loved going to
school
what a joyful time it was
back then we were able to run between
classrooms with ease to visit our
friends
and i remember the way the cafeteria
smelled at lunchtime on hamburger
thursdays
it was right around lunchtime on a
tuesday that the gunman entered the
school through a main door without
restriction
massacred 19 students and two teachers
and changed the way that every student
at rob and their family remember that
school forever
i doubt the remember the smell of the
cafeteria or the laughter ringing in the
hallways
instead they'll be haunted by the memory
of screams and bloodshed panic and chaos
police shouting parents wailing
i know i will never forget what i saw
that day
for me that day started like any typical
tuesday in our pediatric clinic moms
calling for coughs boogers sports
physicals right before the summer rush
school was out in two days then summer
camps would guarantee some grazes and
ankle sprains
injuries that could be patched up and
fixed with a mickey mouse sticker as a
reward
then at 12 30 business as usual stopped
and with it my heart
a colleague from the san antonio trauma
center texted me and said
why are pediatric surgeons and
anesthesiologists on call for a mass
shooting in uvalde
i race to the hospital to find parents
outside yelling children's names in
desperation
and sobbing as they beg for any news
related to their child
those mothers cries i will never get out
of my head
as i entered the chaos of the er i the
first casualty i came across was mia
she was sitting in the hallway her face
was still
still clearly in shock but her whole
body was shaking from the adrenaline
coursing through it
the white lilo and shirt that she wore
was covered in blood
and her shoulder was bleeding from a
shrapnel injury
sweet mia i've known her my whole life
as a baby she survived major liver
surgeries against all odds
and once again she's here
as a survivor
inspiring us with her with her story
today and her bravery
when i saw mia sitting there i remember
having seen her parents outside
so after quickly examining two other
patients of mine in the hallway with
minor injuries i raced outside to let
them know that mia was alive
i'll tell you why i became a
pediatrician because i knew that
children were the best patients
they accept the situation i just
explained to them
you don't have to coax them into
changing their lifestyles in order to
get better or plead them to modify their
behavior as you do with adults
no matter how hard you try to help an
adult their path to healing is always
determined by how willing they are to
take action
adults are stubborn
we're resistant to change even when the
change will make things better for
ourselves
but especially when we think we're
immune to the fallout
why else would have been such little
progress made in congress to stop gun
violence
innocent children all over the country
today are dead because laws and policy
allows people to buy weapons before
they're legally old enough to even buy a
pack of beer
they're dead because restrictions have
been allowed to lapse they're dead
because there are no rules about where
guns are kept because no one is paying
attention to who is buying them
the thing i can't figure out is whether
our politicians are failing us out of
stubbornness
passivity or both
i said before that as grownups we have a
convenient habit remembering the good
and forgetting the bad
never more so that when it comes to our
guns
once the blood is rinsed away from the
bodies of our loved ones and scrubbed
off the floors of the schools and
supermarkets and churches the carnage
from each scene is erased from our
collective conscience and we return
again to nostalgia
to the rose into the view of our second
amendment as a perfect instrument of
american life
no matter how many lives are lost
i chose to be a pediatrician i chose to
take care of children
keeping them safe from preventable
diseases i can do
keeping them safe from bacterial and
brittle bones i can do
but making sure our children are safe
from guns
that's the job of our politicians and
leaders
in this case you are the doctors
and our country is the patient
we are lying on the operating table
riddled with bullets like the children
of rob elementary and so many other
schools
we are bleeding out and you are not
there
my oath as a doctor means that i signed
up to save lives
i do my job
and i guess it turns out that i am here
to plead to beg
to please please
do yours